hello everybody and welcome to episode
number three of my 0er to1 bill progress
videos um today we are going to get some
quests done we are going to get some
skills leveled up and we're going to
make some money uh so to start off here
you can see we are running our route to
do the mort my fungus told you I'd show
you exactly how I did it uh so basically
what I do is I start in edil I run down
here with the Draymond staff uh activate
the portal and then go to
bkr uh which is the closest fairy ring
teleport to the morm fungus and then I
just run West for just 5 Seconds really
and you're just looking for a kind of
triple bit of logs um not that one
unfortunately cuz that's a little too
far apart but this one just coming up
here it's perfect all you're going to do
is get your Enchanted sickle or bless
sickle or what the [__] it is and yeah
cast it pick them up I recommended you
should probably have a higher prayer
level than mine cuz you can see that um
unfortunately IUN another prayer pretty
frequently but I know it works probably
getting about 400k an hour doing this uh
so it's quite decent honestly not very
high requirements or anything and yeah
so we're just going to pick up the
fungus now for what we're going to do
this episode I think we're going to uh
start leveling up our farming a little
bit and we're going to also level up our
agility because that's a good skill to
get at the very beginning of the game uh
which is a bit of a grind but getting
the graceful set is definitely quite
nice cuz you just saves you so much time
in the long run run so you might as well
get it done in the beginning if you're
going to play this game for a while and
yeah there you can see I'm pretty much
all out of prayer just like one more
cast and there we go we're going to pick
up these and then once I'm done we are
going to teleport to uh Clan Wars uh the
reason I'm doing this is just to
recharge my prayer I'm not sure if
there's a quicker way probably is but um
yeah so you just run up here to the
alter and
rejuvenate prey whatever you want to do
to get your prayer back and then you
teleport back to edgil and then you
repeat and yeah so we're going to grind
up some of these to begin with and get
some starting cash okay so we got a
little tired of that so we're going to
just call it for now um we got about 775
plus the 200 we already had should give
us roughly around a mil uh we'll try to
sell for the high price now they have
crashed a bit uh we'll leave it in there
for the price we sold the other ones at
for a while just to see if they will
sell and yeah think we're going to start
on farming to begin with and while we're
waiting uh do some agility so it looks
like we have to start with Oak saplings
uh which is not too bad I think they
give about 500 XP
each and yeah we got the super compost
so yeah we'll run around to do a couple
Farm runs and yeah start the agility I
think this is the easiest way to do it
yeah I'm not even joking I've been here
for 2 minutes raking these freaking
leaves I don't know why it's taking so
long this is
insane okay so we have all the trees
planted so we're just here at the gnome
stronghold agility course just run
around circles we hit level two so
nothing too big uh but yeah we'll get to
level 10 here and then move on to the uh
uh drainer course okay so we're just
going through the final two but we are
just about to hit 10 agility doesn't
take too long and there we are 10
agility so we'll headit to the drainer
course now okay there we're at the
drainer agility course um just going to
do this to level 20 uh but we just hit
level 15 which is nice and yeah five
more levels and there's level 20 agility
got five marks of Grace so far so go
pretty slow on the marks of Grace but
what can you do really okay so we're
just finishing our farm run now there's
19 farming just doing this before
actually had actually been three hours
so we'll Harvest these trees quickly and
then get back to the agility
grind okay so the farm run actually got
us three levels actually pretty much a
level per inspection or tree Harvest or
whatever you want to call it and we're
just about to hit 25 agility there it
is and yeah five more levels and we can
move on to the verac course so we got
nine marks of gray so far we're just
about to hit Level 30 almost just a
couple more obstacles so I think we
about five in the banks we're 15 so far
so I mean this is really slow but uh I
guess that's why people complain about
all the
time but yeah they did not uh understate
it too much this is going to take quite
a while uh but there's level 30 agility
and now we go to the verac course okay
so all the mort my fungus has sold so
this should get this about 1 mil in
coins just to kind of work with here so
y we got
1,9k so a nice start to our cash T um
most of this is going to be reinvested
into our skills um it's not really worth
hoarding it to begin with um but we did
get 16 marks of Grace and we are done to
jilie for now I think we're going to do
some questing um so I think what we're
going to start by doing is the Grand
Tree Quest um gives a good amount of
experience we need access to the
teleportation tree dude and yeah we'll
just get this Quest started these Fair
rings are so useful this guy usually
takes forever to get to but look there's
a ring right there literally can just
run right up that is quite efficient
RuneScape cutcenes got to love
them okay so I think I can just safe
spot this pretty easily so I just
brought magic cuz um seemed to be the
easiest route to take here pretty sure
there's a safe spot just over where the
glow glue glow whatever this guy's
called a standing should be able to oh I
just staff whacked him um I don't I'll
find the face a safe spot and kill this
guy shouldn't be too bad and there we go
the black demon is almost dead one more
shot and there we go perfect um pretty
easy battle and then we just basically
have to do one more thing and then the
quest is done wow that was way quicker
usually it takes like tons of time
trying to find where the stupid stone is
in The Roots but yeah got a first try
actually which is pretty nice and yeah
that's pretty much the quest complete
just got to go through some text here
and yeah I think it gives a bunch of
attack experience and access to the tree
teleportation system like I said this
guy won't shut up oh and Agility
experience too that is actually quite
useful and a little bit of magic
experience so let's see what levels we
get we got four agility levels which is
actually quite useful cuz that's so damn
slow um four attack levels which is
always nice and I think one or two magic
levels whatever uh which is still cool
and always helps and there is level 24
farming we just finished one more Farm
run and yeah getting a little bit closer
to that 30 2 okay so we're just
finishing up one more Farm run H just
got us to level 26 farming which is
pretty nice still got a good amount of
levels left I think it gets quicker once
I get the fruit trees though so we're
just gearing up to do a couple more
quests with the ultimate goal of getting
our defense levels up a bit but um we're
going to do via Quest just to get some
of them knocked out of the way so what
we're going to do is Merlin's Crystal
and
then uh the Holy Grail quest to get some
defense experience also giv us a bunch
of prayer experience as well and yes
with the ultimate goal of doing Slayer
pretty soon to get the Rune plate body
okay so we just pretty much finished um
Merlin's Crystal actually very quick
Quest so all we have to do is drop this
bat Bones on the ground I
think yeah sweet there we go and there
is
the I don't know what this guy is Ghost
sure and so we just have to say a spell
and he should submit to us if we can
remember it so we did actually have to
look at the wiki I didn't actually
remember at all but there we go that's
pretty much the quest complete we just
have to run downstairs now this Quest
doesn't actually give any EXP experience
doesn't really give anything good
however it does give you six Quest
points which I think is the most of any
Quest and since we need 32 Quest points
to do dragon slayer it's actually quite
useful and we just have to talk to King
Arthur and the quest will be complete
scalibur is pretty much useless but yeah
there we go Quest complete and yeah we
will move on to uh Holy Grail so we've
started the quest um this does take
quite a bit longer so we're running
around doing a couple things um but we
will have to gear up to fight the black
Titan pretty soon and I I don't really
know what fishing has to do with this
that s a fisher king am I missing
something from the like King Arthur
story in the round table I don't know
anyway um I have to go find six heads
and yeah she just basically says good
luck with that and yeah we will go ahead
and progress with the quest okay here is
a black Titan so we have to Flinch it
because it is very strong comparatively
to me and it is very tanky so it takes
forever to kill so it's been about 5
minutes and um it did take quite a while
but I mean it is nice I can at least do
this I don't have to go ahead and train
my gear up at all uh but the last hit
does have to be with the Excalibur Sword
and the Excalibur sword really kind of
sucks so we oh there we go he's dead and
yeah that took a while okay so we have
just finishing up the quest here and
11,000 prayer XP and 15,000 defense
experience let's see what levels that
getes us to um 40 prayer so that's three
prayer levels
and 34 defense so four defense levels
pretty good and yeah that pretty much
sets us up for Dragon
Slayer okay so for the last little bit
of the episode we are just going to try
tanning some Dragon hid so we used all
our money to buy 500 Green Dragon hides
for about 900k see how long it takes to
tan these and how much money we'll
actually make from it okay so we're done
tanning the hides um honestly only took
15 minutes to tan about 500 and yeah
we'll go sell them quickly and then see
how much we actually make
okay they are sold and we got about 1
mil back so we made 100K in about 15
minutes so that's about 400k an hour we
will definitely try that again in a
later episode so that's it guys I hope
you enjoyed uh episode three of my 0 to1
bill series we got a lot of progress
done today and I look forward to making
the next episode again remember to hit
that like button and I'll see you guys
in episode 4
a